last week a new trademark application
was filed for Beyond Good and Evil
giving us hope that the sequel may be
coming after all now plenty of vaporware
games do exist that is games that are
announced and then disappear into the
ether never to be released now I was a
big fan of the first Beyond Good and
Evil game so today I'm going to talk
about former vaporware games that were
eventually really
some games emerged from the depths of
development with grace and critical
acclaim shook Nukem Forever was not one
of those games first announced in 1997
when 3d graphics for a brand new thing
duke nukem forever with being created by
3d realms formally RPG games the
developer of the original games it was a
decade before fans got a teaser trailer
in 2007 the game then changed developers
to 2k after a legal battle with tape too
and eventually after 14 years of
development and many delays Duke Nukem
Forever came out with the help of
gearbox software and well there's a
pointed the hell out of everyone
unfortunately the game actually looked
and played like it belongs in 1997 not
every vaporware horror story ends in
failure bo I mean just look at fallout 3
Black Isle Studios headed development of
Fallout and fallout 2 but their parent
company interplay entertainment went
bankrupt to wild black I'll working on
fallout 3 which was codenamed van buren
the license to create fallout 3 was
eventually sold to Bethesda for just
under 2 million dollars and they ignored
all of the work already done on the game
and begun work on their own fallout 3
from scratch once Bethesda wrapped up
development on a little game called the
old scrolls oblivion play set to work on
creating their 3d fallout game which
would arrive four years later and be
totally awesome fortunately aspects of
black Isles original fallout 3 story did
surface in Fallout New Vegas thanks to
obsidian entertainment whose co-founder
Chris Avellone was the lead designer on
the original van buren flat 3 project
another game that kept us waiting this
time for almost a decade it was team
fortress 2 in 1998 a valve told patient
fans that team fortress 2 would be out
shortly well shortly turned out to be
nine years later Team Fortress began as
a popular quake Ahmad whose craters
ended up being hired by Val
same Bulger's to evolved behind the
scenes from a modern strategic war game
to a cartoonish fast-paced multiplayer
shooter after two delays team fortress 2
entered six long years of silent
development unfortunately the game that
arrived was critically acclaimed and
exactly what fans were after and we've
been treated to free updates and
hilarious promotional videos episodes
these days a nine month delay feels like
forever so spare a thought for those who
had to wait through a four year delay to
play stalker shadow of Chernobyl for the
uninitiated stalker is a survival horror
shooter that is set in an alternative
reality where a second nuclear disaster
occurs at Chernobyl much like every
other game on this list shadow of
chernobyl suffered a load of delays
publisher THQ even ran a competition to
let gamers play a beta version of the
game ahead of its release but the
organizers weren't actually able to get
their hands on any copies of the games
for the winners to play awkward just two
months later though the game was
released and while it was plagued with
quite a lot of bugs the game was praised
for its rich world and level design and
was followed up by a sequel call of
pripyat finally well half life 3 doesn't
qualify for this episode since it's
still in that vaporware hole we can talk
about Black Mesa like Mesa was intended
as a third-party remake of hope life I
don't get two lovely one at that but it
sure did take a while as black mesas
eight-year development period was
peppered with delays so far you can play
remakes of chapters from Black Mesa
inbound to lambda core these sections
were released as a standalone download
in 2012 and hip steam early access in
2015 Black Mesa is aiming to recreate
the whole of half-life in the source
engine and the dev team has 40 volunteer
designers the project has migrated
engines multiple times most recently
over two valves 2013 version of the
source engine it also features a
gorgeous score from Joel Nielsen which
is among my personal favorite
soundtracks in all of gaming so okay
this one isn't actually completely
finished yet but at least we got
something to
is going let me know down in the
comments which of these games is your
favorite and which game you'd like to
see escape the vaporware hold for me it
definitely has to be beyond good and
evil to leave me I thought and I will
see you again soon